avec la paire de ces derniers jours
concernant benjamin griveaux un
véritable débat de société autour du
respect de la vie privée est en train de
s'ouvrir en france ces dernières années
la frontière entre vie publique et vie
privée semble de plus en plus minces et
les réseaux sociaux sont un véritable
accélérateur de ce phénomène alors que
pas moins de 4 millions de français ont
consulté les vidéos sexuelles de
benjamin griveaux publié par un
activiste russe le danger de voir ces
photos et vidéos personnellement dévoilé
sur internet est de plus en plus présent
appeler revenge porn comprenez revanche
pornographiques ce phénomène prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur à travers le
monde
4 % des américains de 15 ans et plus
aurait déjà été victime de cette
pratique quand on sait qu'en france un
jeune sur trois a déjà envoyé une vidéo
intime à un tiers depuis son téléphone
portable le phénomène a de quoi
inquiéter en france on se souvient par
exemple de laure manaudou qui en 2007
avait été victime de la diffusion de
photos intimes d'elle de la part de son
ex petit ami plus récemment c'est une
vidéo intime du chroniqueur jeremstar
qui avait été diffusée sur internet aux
états unis en 2014 un gigantesque
piratage des données personnelles des
utilisateurs de la marque apple avait
mené à la diffusion de la part de
hackers de milliers d' images
pornographiques de stars parmi elles
avril lavigne amber heard emma watson ou
encore jennifer lawrence
justin bieber le prince harry ou encore
rihanna figurent eux aussi dans la
longue liste des stars victimes de ce
phénomène alors photos intimes dévoilé
sur les réseaux sociaux
sommes nous tous en danger
idriss nous a rejoint informaticien
spécialisé dans le piratage
iris il va vous faire flipper votre tête
s'échappe à rentrer dans vos portables
peut rentrer dans vos vies heurté dans
vos coeurs ils en auront été dans nos
sites
idriss ya salaires dangereux comme dans
aida même est inquiète alors non publie
la sphère benjamin griveaux est ce que
c'est un cas isolé ou est-ce que ça peut
arriver à tout le monde ça peut arriver
à tout le monde que vous soyez un
particulier un professionnel une pme une
multinationale une star un humoriste ça
peut arriver à vraiment n'importe qui
c'est passé lui envoyer des vidéos quand
même donc ça il a envoyé les vidéos mais
au jour d'aujourd'hui même si vous êtes
sûr que vous êtes sur votre portable va
l'envoyer pas ou la supprimer elle et
elle peut être retrouvé moi je prends
votre portable ne serait ce que 5
secondes je peux récupérer l'intégralité
des jeux vidéo
virons avec mes naim ont chanté du
enrico macias
on est de dire que même si on la
supprime et on va trouver la motivation
mais dans notre portable
on peut la retrouver même si vous l'avez
supprimé du réseau social soit facebook
twitter et youtube
au niveau des rotules non c'est entendez
ça même si vous l'avez supprimés on peut
la retrouver et facebook lundi facebook
le désir qu'il dise que les deux titres
instauré pendant un certain temps même
si vous fermez votre compte les données
stockées pendant plusieurs années
alors là obligeant les gens se disent
pourquoi quel est le conseil qu'on peut
voir ce que même si on les supprime ça
on fait comment ces femmes pour les
femmes ne pouvaient rien faire casser le
port d'armes sans vous casser le
portable vous le pignon de la wii je
vais vous dire ça est un peu plus
compliqué d'accord il appartient moment
le portable est toujours en vie même si
ce ne serait ce que la vitre avant
tactique assez sérieux on peut quand
même récupérer les datas ouais y'a pas
de soucis
oui c'est pourquoi une explication je
lis il a fait recours très intéressant
c'est qu'on a une photo qu'on prétend
sur ton teva on les fasse par exemple
l'effacer que virtuellement faire
qu'elles existent à faire on cache dans
l'ordre dans le téléphone
en fait c'est l'heure de l'autre on dit
que c'est l'espace disponible pour
l'effacer dire que c'est de la place
mais elle est toujours là
circuit pour la supprimer comment il
m'en faudrait faire plein de photos sur
le défunt pour effacer toute la mémoire
complet sur une vocation vous êtes en
crypté ça va être difficile
un crypto cryptée accepter ou pas
accepté d'ailleurs c'est dire que même
si vous supprimez la vidéo vous avez
gagné un peu des spasmes et vous
gagnerez pas l'espace complet sur votre
portable y aura toujours un petit espace
réduit et cette vidéo est récupérable et
déchiffrable glisse pour être tranquille
alors il n'y a pas de bon il ya des
conseils de bon sens pour essayer de
réduire ses risques mais ces risques
sont là et seront toujours notre manière
l'un d'entre eux serait par exemple
quand vous chatter avec quelqu'un sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est vraiment
vérifié l'intégrité du profil parce
qu'aujourd'hui un profil est modulable
et modifiables je peux faire un profil
de cyril hanouna demain est envoyé chez
pas 3 millions d'abonnés 4 millions
d'abonnés me faire passer pour vous très
facilement mettre la pastille bleue
viendra non festive le vérifier à ne pas
divulguer bien entendu de vidéos intimes
que ce soit sur what's app sur facebook
sur sur n'importe quel social de
messagerie sécurisée c'est pipeau alors
alors message de sécuriser tout et pipo
sauf télégramme pour moi je voudrais les
boutiques attention parce que il ya la
manière d'utiliser t g dire si vous
utilisez t g normalement ce sera pas
crypté il faut vraiment faire démarrer
un échange secret pour qu'on puisse pas
faire des captures d'écran et que
vraiment les données soit supprimée au
fur et à mesure c'est ça exactement il
ya un système d'autodestruction que vous
choisissez donc soit une seconde une
minute alors nous dit aussi qu'il faut
arrêter les mots de passe simple bah
c'est sûr si vous utilisez vous par
exemple cyril 1 2 3 on va vous trouver
facilement on va vous prêter facilement
gérer 4 5 6 le truc qu'il faudrait faire
le truc qu'il faudrait faire à mon avis
ce serait mettre un mot de passe sur un
peu complexe avec une majuscule ou
plusieurs majuscule et des chiffres et à
quelque chose qui n'a aucun rapport avec
vous pas le nom de votre chien bien j'ai
mis le nom de mon amoureuse
aurore castaldi quatre heures
la note sont aussi également c'était
voilà tout ce qu'ils réseau public donc
quand vous connecter que ce soit dans un
aéroport que ce soit dans un rêve et
faire très attention parce que toutes
les données qui transitent sur son
réseau en question elles sont
récupérables puisque le réseau n'est pas
sécurisé en lui-même ne soit dans un tgv
oui ils vont manger tranquillement des
haies melaine n'avait qu'une quiche à 52
euros vous soyez une première erreur sur
le deuxième une pour une personnalité ou
un particulier une simple antenne ça
suffit de récupérer les données qui
transitent justement sur les téléphones
dire par exemple vous allez faire un
achat dans un tgv en étant connecté au
réseau public
on peut récupérer vos données bancaires
on peut récupérer tout ce que vous les
toiles à issia le petit caleb le ctps
ces moustiques et des débris ont laissé
dans son jet privé on vous aussi de
petits tours effectivement notamment
quand on va acheter sur sur sur certains
sites ya 110 ans le site https avec moi
et on dit qu'il faut toujours qu'ils
connaissent pour que jusqu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui moi je peux vous
développer un site admettions ainsi de
déblocage des portables pour 1 euro vous
allez faire un achat dessus aura le
https mais les données bancaires j'aurai
récupéré par dont paypal c'est plus
sécurisé paypal c'est plus sécurisé mais
là encore il ya des ddd failli parce que
si on sort un peu du sujet si vous
voulez c'est au niveau de paypal on peut
récupérer vos identifiants et faire des
paiements avec donc verser vous êtes
passé c'est faire l'avocat d'un des
photos intimes par des jeux être
définitivement supprimée ou ces morts
après on vous parlait sur les réseaux
sociaux au niveau de votre partenaire
niveau de notre portable à ses morts ses
mots ont fait trois morts
c'est moi et ils vont sortir je tiens la
seule manière pour vraiment
supprimer une vidéo de votre portable
c'est de péter votre portable d'accord
c'est impossible sinon c'est impossible
elle sera récupérable d'une manière ou
d'une autre à wayss & more ses moves à
oued en quelques secondes avec un câble
je pourrais vous faire une démo si vous
voulez voir quelques secondes si je
voulais sur mon portable
elle récupère l'intégralité de donner
les appels sms qui est d'accord alors
sauf que ça c'est des conseils de bon
sens à suivre pour réduire les risques
mais bien entendu aujourd'hui les
risques ils sont énormes et très
important et ça touche tout le monde
vraiment soin particulier incroyable or
even sporn consiste à mettre en ligne
des vidéos des photos à caractère sexuel
sans l'autorisation de la personne
concernée par vengeance c'est ce qu'on
dit cette pratique est parfois
accompagnés de chantage ou de menaces
depuis 2007 cette pratique est passible
de deux ans de prison les 60000 euros
damende je vous le dit voilà il ya un
joli ce matin et olivier capa qui était
l'invité de jean marc morandini sur ses
news l'artiste a été victime de riven
sporn lui aussi voilà il y en a plein
bien sûr il ya gas lift filiale affaires
griveaux il y en a plein d'autres y à
paris s'il tonne
au départ alors sur ça on peut rien
faire mais on peut rien faire et le
phénomène risque de s'amplifier et de
s'empirer sans pour autant sortir du
sujet ce qui moi mon avis moi ce qui
c'est ce qui risque d'arriver dans les
prochaines années ou dans les prochains
mois c'est plutôt du dif fait que c'est
dire qu'aujourd'hui mois avec photoshop
les algorithmes spécialisé une
intelligence artificielle je prends une
photo de vous maintenant je vous retire
votre barbe je vous met à poil
je fais ce que je veux de vous avec une
simple photo et c'est vraiment rester
bravo
on sort de là à partir de là c'est très
simple de relayer l'information qui sera
fausse mais aux yeux du public ça
paraîtra vraiment comme un acte réel moi
c'est bon c'est bon c'est à dire on peut
faire des trucs presque vrai il ya vu
une application à l'époque était sortie
qui s'appelait deep news qui passe rien
entendu parler qui a été supprimée 24
heures après les par les craintes qui
sont impressionnants mais en gros vous
faites une photo de la tête d'une
personne d'un chroniqueur ou n'importe
quoi qui rend public et ma vie ça va le
mettre à poil tout simplement away le
module y est très facilement accordées
sur moi je vous le faire mais
aujourd'hui c'est chez nous peut le
faire surtout jean michel maire on peut
le faire on peut le faire
alors que la semaine prochaine bah bien
sûr non mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
aussi qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire si
on vous donne notre portable pendant 5
secondes ou à distance qu'est ce que
vous pouvez faire à distance qu'on peut
faire c'est par exemple procéder à
l'envoi de mms
à partir du moment où j'ai exécuté le
mma votre fort le mms
encore pardon ms c'est l'ancienne
génération dire ce qu'on veut dans les
parois de s'appeler photos et autres ça
passe par le réseau mobile et à partir
du moment où vous avez exécuté ce ms
votre portable est infectée ne le verrez
pas on a accès aux appels là encore ou
sms au facebook on peut faire des
captures d'écran ce qui se passe écoutez
si la reconnaissance vocale écouter ce
qui se passe autour de votre portable
configuration c'est à dire je suis en
train de parler avec quelqu'un alors
exactement c'est sûr que moi je vais
vous zappez sur votre portable se faire
une certaine configuration et ça va
votre portable a sonné ça va répondre
automatiquement et vous ne le verrez pas
vous pouvez continuer à apprendre ce qui
se passe exactement pas offert aussi une
démonstration dans ce cadre structurel
important
[Rires]
le rival m'importe c'est un vrai
phénomène social qui inquiète beaucoup
les victimes sont à 90% des femmes et ça
débouche souvent sur du chantage mais
aussi du harcèlement si vous avez trois
conseils à donner à nos téléspectateurs
c'est comme ça que je n'ai 2
précédemment le teaser donne à
l'utilisation d'un mot de passe
compliquée vers les publics à éviter pas
ouvrir les mms des personnes qu'on ne
connaît pas ne pas divulguer de vidéos
intimes que ce soit sur votre portable
ou n'importe où dans les réseaux sociaux
les conserver pour vous et
éventuellement les transmettre à des
membres que vous êtes un fanatique de
confiance et puis voilà moi comme je
disais ça touche vraiment tout le monde
du particulier aux professionnels
aujourd'hui on a une plate forme
s'appelle promenade point com où on est
vraiment que ce soient des particuliers
et les pme
les grosses sociétés les multinationales
justement à sortir de ce pétrin là et en
même temps à consolider leurs plus
popularité certaine appel à vous pour
nettoyer leurs portes à l'histoire
peut-être qu'ils sont sur le plateau là
et où peut-être qu'ils étaient déjà
passées sur ce plateau la voix c'est
vrai ah ouais rien à laver lave o
pourquoi pourquoi pour construire des
pour consolider leur compteur de
follower pour améliorer leur popularité
on a des gars serviable mais les
personnes qui sont passés ici ou dans
d'autres plateaux en direct etc ont eu
des gros problèmes sur ce qu'ils ont dit
et suite à ça leur popularité a chuté
ils ont fait appel à nos services pour
monter leur popularité croît les
assimiler supprimer les commentaires
négatifs et les remplir de commentaires
positifs par dessus c'est franchement on
apprend des choses réseaux sociaux est
ce qu'on peut se faire un truc qui dit
saint girons est ce que tu peux venir et
nous faire un des trucs en direct abbey
a aucun souci c'est vrai et il paraît
que tu peux faire des trucs de fou pas
que tu peux mettre ses huit sur tf1
c'est possible vraiment possible
ah non mais c'est pas une blague
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
inouï ce que vous avez vu comme il
explique bien des choses et on les voit
revenir dans l'émission je dois faire
des choses est trop tard à une spéciale
des mots je pense semaine prochaine tu
vas nous faire des démos en direct vous
allez voir ça ça va être complètement
fou